welcome everybody to our next dc
thursdays
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council and the data community fund
and as you know we've been
producing these programs these
interviews every other week
on thursdays to talk to a leader in the
open source data world
so today i'm very excited to have
stephon ewan here he's the co-founder
and the cto
of riverica which is the core company
behind apache flink
so staphon welcome thanks pete for
having me
yeah it's great to have you here um i'm
in
wyoming you're in berlin but through the
wonders of the internet
we're able to do a coveted safe session
right
so tell me um what's the big idea
with streaming it seems like
it's a paradigm shift it's an
architecture that
is very different than the batch
architecture that many companies are
familiar with
it requires some new thoughts some new
thinking
all things that we'll discuss in the
program but i just wanted to ask you
like what's the
what's the big idea here behind
streaming yeah
um it's it's actually not i think one
idea
that that's the thing that that makes
streaming big i think streaming is where
where a few things finally like come
together and
and form from like a um a good
whole big picture which is what what
makes it so interesting but
let's actually go through through a few
of these things that motivate folks to
to use it
um so the i'd say the first thing that
that most people think about when they
when they're here streaming is
sure it's um it's it's definitely a way
to to reduce the
the time to to acting on the data you
know um
rather than um then going with the
battery way of
you know data gets produced you keep
gathering it for a while ingesting it
into some
some data lake or so and then you run
your analysis maybe end of the day or so
streaming really
continuously processes and acts on the
data so
it's definitely a much um it's
definitely a great way to say
um i want to you know like reduce the
time to action uh
for for my data but it's it's not just
that it's um if it were just that then
it would be you know like a second thing
that you that you add in addition to
what you already have you know and
that's kind of how it started to be
honest like there was the fast data path
and the slow data path
but i think when you talk about like
streaming today maybe it's
kind of like the second or third
generation of streaming people sometimes
call it it's
it's this um it's this yeah like i said
it's a different paradigm tool to think
about it
it's a way to to really
model and treat data as this continuous
sequence of events
um which is quite natural because mostly
that's really how data is produced you
know like as
as events coming from a user interacting
with a service coming from a from a
sensor or a device
um producing a reading and so on and
um yeah and streaming you you really
acknowledge and kind of
embrace this nature and then um then
model your applications
as as processing of of these events
right
batch has in in some way a bit of a a
simplifying but also a bit of an
unnatural assumption right like here's a
terabyte of data type out of that is
there's not a terabyte of data appearing
out of nowhere it usually was a stream
at some point in time that you that you
gathered and you know
batched up before you processed it and
in streaming you kind of skipped the
step you go directly on
on working on the data as it's naturally
produced and this is
if you start to model your applications
like this it's it's a very
it's a very both a natural way once you
once you start embracing this and it's
also um
kind of a unifying way because you you
can still
actually do the battery processing of
that you can still if you wish like take
the stream
and buffer it up in your message queue
in
a data lake and and still process it as
a batch but
because you started to model and treat
it like a stream you could also
just switch it around and say i'm not
buffering and batching it up i'm acting
really on the events as they come so you
have kind of this paradigm that allows
you to
to go to do both things depending just
on
on a configuration almost if you wish
that's that's very powerful
i know that's one of the things that
we'll talk about today is
this notion of actually being able to
use flink as both a stream
and or a batch processor which is
something that i know you're excited
about i don't think that's
something that that flink supported in
v1
so we want to talk about that today um
before i i continue i want to ask you
about the origin story of link
but i also want to mention to the
audience and remind them that
if anyone has questions we've been
having a lot of fun
doing um sort of audience guided
discussions over the last couple
episodes and so
if you have questions for stuff on um
about flink about streaming in general
um please drop them in the youtube chat
comments and
i'll be taking questions as we go along
so that's a fun way to
affect the conversation from your end um
so staphon before we get into some some
more of the uh nitty-gritty details
architecturally about
flink which i'm excited to hear um tell
me about the origin story like
how how and why did flink come to be
yeah um yeah that's it's
that that's it's an interesting one so
um
in in some sense flink say as a
university
research project spin off um started out
with the
with a bunch of people most of of who
later became
you know early early commanders and pmc
members of link and also
founders of back then data artisans um
we're working
at the university in berlin on on a
research project and the way it started
out it was
it was very you know i could say vaguely
defined you know hadoop was just a cool
thing back then and then the project
just
um just set out and said okay you know
hadoop it's pretty cool but
also it it kind of dropped let's say
20 30 years of of results of technology
and research um results from
like from the database community so
let's let's start and see if we can kind
of
bring these things together a bit and
then and what what year was this stuff
it was just 2012 or
29 actually 29 was when that
was when that started it was not it was
not apache flink back then it was a
research project called stratosphere um
yeah so we were working on this at the
at the university and
um you know that that's kind of how the
project started out but it
it it kind of took a bit of a different
direction then because you know how
these projects go and
it actually ended up with us building a
system for like
diverse use cases of data processing
with kind of a
um yeah somewhat of a streaming
streaming back-end even though you know
streaming wasn't a big thing back then
i think storm was just was just starting
to
become a known project and yeah and
in the end we we actually did have a
batch processor with a streaming
streaming back end in the end that's um
that was the the result
um it sounds a bit strange like why
would you do that but there's actually
some interesting
properties to that and like for research
project it made a lot of sense back then
especially for the use cases we wanted
to look at um
so we're actually quite quite excited
about the result of this
of this project and and we're thinking
okay let's let's see what we what we can
do out of this and um so we took this to
the apache software foundation with a
few initial users
and committers and um and started
working on this and
and i think during the first year when
we were working on this i think this is
when the idea of streaming started to
become
like really more more crisp and popular
not not just in our heads i think this
is
um i think both the adoption of storm um
was there i think sparks streaming was
released during that time and i think
i think kafka version 08 or so just came
out and you could see people becoming
really interested in that
but also there wasn't really a good
stream processor around this this
this concepts of event time where
basically i think nowhere
um yet other in a few google research
papers
um this notion of being able to do
exactly once
both with low latency and high
throughput there wasn't really a system
out there that could do that and
um we realized that we actually had a
pretty interesting thing in our hands
which was which was fairly close without
actually doing this right like
the back end was actually very very well
designed to to handle these these
challenges it's just like we never
exposed any of that
because the use cases we were looking at
were very much
bad use cases actually and and then we
realized that
you know let's let's just try and make
an experiment and put it put a streaming
api there just
to see if that's interesting to somebody
and it and it was actually it was very
surprising it was like very very
interesting to a lot of people um
because of of this yeah exactly once low
latency throughput notion you could get
because of the
of the flexibility and the um and the
event entire model that
um that we were able to like quickly
manage um
google data google dataflow was was
published i think as an as an open
source
sdk during that time we're pretty
quickly able to integrate with that
because like all these concepts just
matched really well between the systems
and
um yeah so that i think that's that's
kind of how flink came to be a streaming
system even though
it's actually if you can think about it
a batch project when it started
and then you started uh in around 200
2014
i guess that's right yeah um it was not
called verico back then it was
called data artisans that's um it's the
name of the company we started right
that was 2014 maybe half a year after
um we open sourced the project
um under the umbrella of the apache
software foundation
got it and um how do you see people
um using flink today like what are the
main use cases where somebody would
sort of take this plunge into streaming
because i still feel like
um even though like you said we're
probably in the third generation or so
of streaming tech and
there's many options out there um as we
all know many competing options
um which i'm sure you have insights on
um what's the tipping point for
most folks in like what's the what's the
most common use case for them to
actually
dive in and and get their feet wet with
streaming like what does that typically
look like from your perspective
um um i would say this is changing also
a little bit like what are the
what are the common use cases i would
say until
um until a little bit ago one of the
predominant use cases that that folks um
that folks just looked at doing were
were certain things like um
you know low latency fraud detection
anomaly detection
um you know something that was
an unknown under um maybe as a cep if
you go a decade back or so
um but you know that the cp engines from
back then were
a bit like rigid often not very scalable
complex event processing sorry yeah so
that
um meaning you have a set of rules or so
um or patterns that you want to search
for in your data stream
things that may you know may indicate an
anomaly a network intrusion
financial fraud or or just i don't know
a bunch of sensors
um going off in an irregular pattern and
um
something you want to take a look at so
that was that was one of the of the very
common use cases
um another one i would say you could
almost think of it as
like like real-time etl or real-time
real-time dashboards or so where users
were subscribing to some event sources
and they wanted to
yeah to render dashboards and charts in
real time or
or move it in in real time to to another
um
to another database for yeah for
up-to-date um bi quiz or something like
that
this could be potentially for like
analyzing click stream data that seems
to be a common
um use case that i i hear um folks
implement streaming
streaming systems for is that right yeah
absolutely so
um i think from from that time came can
most of the i would say use cases that
are
are very well known so fraud detection i
mentioned that one um
i think the click stream one one you
mentioned um
is is very is very present in um in a
bunch of use cases around record time
recommendations
um so you know a lot of like online
online platforms that that want to give
you real-time content recommendations
based on
on your current interaction and not just
on what they figured out you were doing
a week ago because you know your mood
today might be different than your mood
a few days before so you're interested
in different content um
in fact one of the one of the biggest
use cases that we get in touch
um with alibaba about was one of those
like their entire ecommerce platform is
the searches if you wish one one giant
real-time recommendation system
running on flink so um so those were
those were definitely um
big use cases i would say others are
others that that
um got got also somewhat um popular were
things around that dynamic supply and
demand matching
so let let's say you have a ride sharing
app or someone you're you're interested
in
or it wants to suggest a price and take
lots of things like forecasted supply
and demand traffic patterns and so on
into account
to compute these things continuously in
the background like the parameters based
on which these
these suggestions are then made um those
were those were definitely the the
popular
um use cases and and i would i would say
they still are maybe i shouldn't say
that in the past tense
but uh what i would like to add is in in
some sense one that we see
coming up now more and more is is this
whole idea of
um of like unified real-time and
um real-time and batch analytics so
um i guess this is partly also due to
the
new capabilities of link that it's
really added a lot of
um even though it came from the batch
side when we worked on the streaming
site we're not
you're not paying too much attention to
the batch side for a few years but we've
actually
we've actually added like a lot of
sophistication there over the last two
three releases again
so partly due to these um these changes
and
i'd say also due to the rising
popularity of sql
in the in the streaming world um
these use cases are are very strong
right now so being able to build like a
unified real-time and batch analytics
system
you know just based on a high-level
language like sql is i'd say one of the
prime use cases
um right now that's fascinating well
um that's probably a good segue um i
want to open up
the flink api diagram that we discussed
let me just put that on the screen and i
think i want to give you an opportunity
to
chat through that
there we go so can you talk us through
the the this api stock because i found
this particularly interesting and i'm
hoping it gives you an opportunity to
talk about some of the
architectural decisions that you made
when you were designing flink as well
yeah um sure i think this is a good
good good way to start talking first of
it first through the let's say the api
user facing perspective and then maybe a
little bit through the like
like runtime architecture and an
operational perspective
yeah so um
yeah in this api stack i think you can
you can kind of see that there's
there's different different entry points
to to flink depending on
on the trade-off between you know um
expressiveness and and flexibility
versus
um let's say conciseness declarativity
ease of use
um the maybe we start from the from the
bottom
um if the first things we're really
working on
were um with these these basic building
blocks
um that
i think that give you an amazingly great
flexibility
and and still take a lot of problems
away from you just just
having very powerful um ways of dealing
with
events or even event streams state and
um and various notions of time and and
based on that um you can yeah you can
you can model a lot of things you can
build your
your unified applications you can build
your um
yeah you can build real-time trading
systems and lighting systems and so on
but you're you're in a bit of a
low-level world there because
you're really asking um the user to say
okay you know model your
your java scala classes and so on for
your events
decide when to put something into stage
draw it out of state again
when to schedule timers for callbacks
and so on how to deal with you know
differences between event and processing
time it's very powerful but it's also it
requires
quite a level of understanding of the
model
in the data stream api most of this is
exposed but it gives you a few
also let's say shortcuts to it to just
define you know time windows
something like um tell me what the you
know like the average number of
of visits was in the last in the last
five minutes but but still a very you
know very
that's a physical way of programming um
where you're dealing really with java
and scholar code and so on
um up from there where with the efforts
to to say okay let's let's make this a
bit easier and
accessible to a broader audience i think
we can really say
mostly the sql api and the table api are
the same
um sql is is the textual representation
if you wish on the table api
is a is a domain specific embedded
language but
pretty much with the exact same
exclusivity and an idea so
you're dealing with with tables with a
logical schema
with logical operations everything goes
through an optimizer that you know
deals with the with the details um for
you
so um if you go
if you go to this api you're taking a
slightly different abstraction level
you're now not looking at the individual
events anymore but you're looking at the
concept called like the
dynamic table so um
i think we can we can go into details of
that uh uh in a bit
and then kind of recently i would say
maybe
less than a year ago um python came in
the mix and
yeah just because we we just saw it was
very popular with a lot of users was
one of the most requested features and
um
the the first way we've integrated with
python is actually
um as a way to define user defined
functions in in sql and in the table api
in python
you know if you want a custom aggregate
function or a custom custom table
function or custom
also custom scala function and so on you
can write these in
in java scala and now now also in python
and i think um gradually will will
extend the support
and um and also you know add python
support for the for the lower levels of
the stack
the moment python only supports the
higher levels of the stack
i see um that's great to know i was not
aware that
uh flink had python support now um at
least at that layer so that's uh
that's super interesting i'm sure that
makes the platform
much more easy to use to adopt by a
broader set of
different types of users who don't
necessarily want to muck around with the
job of
the jvm yeah yeah absolutely i mean
especially in the machine learning world
python is
is very very popular and um
and part of this like this vision we
have for flink to
to build this unified system where you
can run
um let's say batch computation and
streaming computation um
interchangeably it makes it also i think
very very attractive in the in the long
run as a as a system for
um for a bunch of machine learning
workloads where on the battery side you
have the um
you have the training of the model on
the streaming side you have the
let's say real-time feature vector
assembly and evaluation of the
of the model and um so
as as a way to you know like look at
look at these use cases
um yeah that was one of the big reasons
of why we also
added python support because i think
these are these are going to be very
interesting use cases for a unified
system
got it well let's dive into that a
little bit more um because i'm sure the
audience is
is very curious to hear about this the
support this dual support for both batch
and stream
um can you walk us through the basic
architecture and i wish i had another
diagram but um can you walk us through
the basic architecture of
of how that all fits together um
yeah so maybe i can quickly
start again like what what does it mean
to use a
like a unified system from from the
programmer's perspective and then see
like how does a
unified runtime actually look um because
that's
that is interestingly uh um actually
they can they can be quite different so
unified apis this this idea has actually
been i think around
for a bit um you know with projects like
summing bird from twitter
um that offloaded parts of the data to
storm parts of the
data to hadoop um projects like beam
that
that look at unified apis and flink is
also doing this
what's i think fairly new is this idea
of using sql for unified system
um and then there there are a bunch of
systems that
that um that try to implement really a
unified runtime one that can do both
batch and streaming
um at the same time i think that their
fling is pretty unique actually
but um take taking a step um
back from the runtime and and looking
first at the abstraction level i think
sql is a very is a very interesting
um way to maybe try and describe this so
um
if you look at what how sql is is
defined it's um
it's a you have a sql query that takes a
bunch of tables
um and and the result of the sql query
is again a table that's
like the relational model some relations
go in you have the query with some some
filters
some you throwing out some columns your
joins doing some joints and aggregates
the results again a table
um in in some sense that's a batchy
model right you're taking a
static set of data a fix table in and
then you're getting a fixed table out
so i think that's also
why it was such a good match for for the
for the batch processors right why hive
became so
popular spark sequel and so on um
um it turns out actually sequel has a
pretty cool meaning in the in the
streaming world as well and
um that is if you if you start start to
to think of a table not as
a static thing but a table is something
that that changes over time like a table
might
you know there might be a row inserted
into the table a row deleted from the
table a row updated
the table and um there's there's
actually very interesting ways to
interpret a stream as a as a
table that is um that is undergoing
changes
um you know i think kafka has pre um has
for example
um talked about this this notion like
stream
table duality tt for a while and this is
really also what i think the idea of
streaming sequel takes if you wish to
the next level so you take a stream of
events um let's say these events
they can go by a primary key and replace
other entries by primary key or they can
also really encode
operations like updates inserts and
deletes
and then then you you arrive at a set of
table that that changes you know as new
events through the
stream come this table changes then we
run a sql query over this changing table
and this actually produces a result
table that's that's not static but
that's that's also changing
you know let's say the the sql query um
is something like
um i don't know tell us the the best
selling project in the geography
um i saw the you're not the best selling
product in the geography of the day
and um you know as new events come in um
this might actually change right so
um before it used to be i don't know why
tennis socks and now it's actually
whatever
um the um i don't know like trainers
so and and so the
that's really what the what the sql
query would would then tell you right um
as
the incoming relation changes it would
tell you okay take away from your
results at that
that pair of um tennis socks and you
know add into your result
um the the night trainers or so because
because the
the result just changed and um
and and that's actually a very that
that's a model that
a lot of people can can get actually
used to just thinking of sql as not
static table to
static result but dynamic table to
dynamic result and then it's really the
question what do you do with this
dynamic result you can of course
like put it in um in another database
over which you
you know from where you visualize it in
a dashboard or you can convert it back
to stream
that says um you know change most
popular product from from this to that
or you can use it to define define
actions on you know if that happens then
trigger this alert and so on
so that that that's really um a way to
to think of of let's say unification of
the analytics from the from the api
perspective
um and and if the nice thing is this is
so well defined actually in the end that
if you
let's say you have you have the stream
of events that produces the table
you run this incremental stream to
dynamic table
dynamic streaming sql query and dynamic
result
if you run through the entire stream you
get you get a final result
if you actually just gather the whole
stream materialize it in one table and
then run a batch query you get the exact
same result
so it's really a way of saying we're
continuously computing this
increment incrementally updating the
result adding your items taking items
out
rather than saying we're first of all
waiting to ingest all data
put it there and then we're running it
in one batch and i think this is this is
a good example to show how to
how to yeah really use this notion of
streaming and
we didn't add something new here we just
kind of generalized the existing right
here
you you start with with sql just
generalize it from a static to a dynamic
table and a static table is kind of just
a special case of dynamic table at the
end
but of course there's there's lots of
other complexity
like under the covers to be able to to
do all this
and um sometimes yes
an application um can't wait for the
the full dynamic table to be like you
know re-materialized and so
the applications um if you're building a
true streaming application
um there's things like windowing and um
sort of acknowledging like what's in a
batch um and other
functions and concepts that are critical
for for streaming right um i think
your checkpoint system probably uh
fits in here somewhere um can you just
walk us through
some of those basic concepts for those
of us who might be new to the streaming
world
right so the um i think what you say was
really it was really important the
um the thing that really makes streaming
different
is this the fact that you have to
to acknowledge that if you're not
looking at a static set of data you do
have to
trade off your latency versus
completeness if you wish right if you
wait a little longer you have
more data and you get a result that's
closer to the final result but it also
takes longer to get the result right the
earlier you ask for a result the less
completed it is right um so that
that is exactly what what requires kind
of the flexible runtime architecture to
be able to if you wish like
dial this knob in the direction that you
need if you're interested in very low
latency
then um you you get you get results that
flow through extremely fast but you know
they they might actually not even be
relevant they might be retracted later
because they're
they get replaced by your results and
then if you're on the very extreme other
end on the batchy end you
you don't emit anything you wait really
long until everything is there and then
you get get it in one chunk
and this and that that really requires
um
so in the in the apis this is this if
you go to the data stream api
you're you're configuring your
watermarks for example just to
throw this out there this is exactly the
modeling of this trade-off of latency
versus completeness that's the
that's the event time watermark um
going to the runtime level now yeah um
this there's a bit of a difference in
how you want to execute um
want to execute streaming versus
business batch queries in in many ways
um for for streaming queries it's
it's quite important to yeah to keep
keep the data running you know
you start every operator um at the same
time an event comes in it has to flow
really fast to the
through the data flow and and produce a
result at least if you're asking for
like
very low latency results for a batch
processor you can really
also do this batchy processing one stage
after the next stage after the next
stage because nobody's asking you
for any results before everything is
done um this actually turns out it's a
very different
it it boils down to very different
algorithms in the runtime
to to do this efficiently and also very
different strategies for fault tolerance
and i think this is really where fling
came up with a with a pretty great idea
um like traditionally the batch
processors really
just did batch processing schedule tasks
recompute the task on failure this is
what you know hotbook does spark does
and so on
um to some extent also what what flink
does if you look at the
at like at pure streaming systems for
example like kafka what they typically
do is they take they take an event from
a queue
process something put it back into
another queue now both of these
both of these models don't don't really
work for the other case like if you put
something from a queue process it put it
back from a queue you can in theory do
batch processing with it but it's just
going to be horribly horribly
inefficient
on the other side the batch system
doesn't even give you a chance of doing
low latency processing
what what flink basically did is it it
came up with a good
it's a good middle ground between those
two things it actually did
build a a pipelined system that really
lets the events flow through really fast
um
and an editor added a full tolerance
mechanism that that doesn't
that doesn't require persisting the
events in in queues in the middle but it
added this checkpointing mechanism where
we you're basically drawn an
asynchronous background
snapshot view of the system and then
um yeah then recovery basically boils
down to
when you hit a failure you analyze what
what operators are connected to that
failure and you
you do actually kind of a similar
recovery as you would do for a batch
system but only back to the to the last
checkpoint
and this actually gives you a very nice
hybrid architecture because for batch
processing
what you do is you just don't run
checkpoints the
there's an implicit if you wish
checkpoint at the beginning of the job
and
tasks fall back to that then it boils
down to the same thing that hadoop and
spark and so on do
for a streaming system you just draw
these snapshots really really quickly
and every time an operator fails like a
small region rewinds to that snapshot
and continues from there so you have a
very a very small amount of work that
you do that you go back
to to redo um once you
once you have a failure and this and i
think this this is
this characteristics really what what um
what the last thing to
to really scale scale really well to to
both types of use cases to the
to the batch processing and uh and the
stream processing use cases
and um there was it was a bit of
serendipity to discover that mechanism
admittedly but it turned out to be
actually
i think like one of one of the very
defining things for flink
and is this one of the core concepts
behind flink's
stateful streams as well or can you
go into that just a little bit because i
think that's an important concept as
well
right yeah so um i think when we talk
about streaming today we
we implicitly talk about stateful
streaming the
i'd say if we go back to how streaming
started
there's a lot of stateless streaming um
which
in some sense just means you take events
maybe transform them and
and root them and there's there's
certain things you can do with that like
some simple forms of streaming etl and
so on or
yeah or or using using streaming to to
connect different systems
um like move data in real time
that is possible but the only thing you
can really do is something that's like
almost
forgetful you can think a bit about it
like that right every event
is on its own it only knows itself and
its content it doesn't know anything
about like what happened before it
um or so and that that really limits the
the use cases for for a lot of
interesting use cases you do want to
know a bit about your context like okay
i'm i'm an event that
you know is somehow suspicious am i the
first one then it might be okay but if
i'm the third one in a row
this this might be something i want to
trigger an alert for um
and this is really the state like this
context that every event has accessible
to know
more than just itself like to know
something about what happened in the
past
and if you if you don't have state then
then then things become really easy then
then recovery also doesn't need to
recover much other than just like
kind of needing to know where where you
left off and and where you have to
continue if you have state you have to
really be careful and correlate where
were you in the stream
what is the changes to your state into
your context this is really what you
need checkpointing
for if you if you don't have state full
stream processing you don't
need anything like checkpoints in the
end but i think the use cases that
are stateless that are not stateful um
[Music]
some users have them when they start but
most users tend to outgrow them really
fast
well let's take a question from the
community
vasilis is asking are you working to add
any adaptive methods
like adaptive random forest
into evolving data right now to any of
your projects
i think that's a that's a
it's a bit of a specific use case um
so from from from what what what fling
is it's
it's basically a um it's at this point
it's a it's a
processing system um fairly use case
independent it does
it does have a few libraries it does not
yet have
a full a full-fledged machine learning
library where for example
you would have some of these algorithms
there is
there are a bunch of ecosystem projects
around flink
um there is a project called a-link
which is a which is a collection of i
think
like almost 100 different machine
learning
algorithms implemented on top of link
it might be that for example some
algorithm like that exists
there but i'm i'm not deep enough into
that project to actually
say this with certainty but if you're if
you're interested in that general space
i would i would
check this out um so yeah
and so so on that note um since since
the topic has been
raised what are the machine learning use
cases or scenarios where
you see flink sort of supporting
advanced machine learning what does that
look like currently today
yeah um so
um i think on the machine learning side
always makes sense to look at um
at two different sites there's the um
there's the set of
of training a machine learning model of
you know of
let's say that that's the that's the
part that the data scientist does
like going through modeling parameters
um um
tuning the model evaluating coming up
with something that you're then happy
with and you want to deploy and then
there's the then there's the side of
um let's say very often the data
engineer that that takes this model um
integrates it with the application and
then you know as as the user comes the
model you know spits out the
recommendation
um i think the
the holy grail kinda is to have a
unified way of doing this to say okay
you know once the
once you've um once you've built the one
side you can just like push it to
production and the other side runs as
well for
some simple use cases that's that's
quite doable for the
more complex ones you also need um
you also need like you need you also
need a bit of data processing work on
the application side
um a good example is a lot of these
fraud detection use cases let's say when
when when a credit card transaction also
comes in
um you usually don't look at it in
isolation and then
try to try to label it as fraudulent or
valid but
usually take a lot of history into
account from that user between the
geographies what do you know about these
these partner banks what what's the
histogram of payment over the hours of
day that you know like these users um
usually had and so on and um that that's
for example where where flink is used a
lot like to assemble this information
real time and supply it to them to the
machine learning model
so that's that's that's where we've
that's where we've started off um
with uh with flink like the um you can
you can see the model evaluation side
set of things um i mentioned it a bit
earlier um when we're talking about
python
there there's some people in the
community that are very interested
in in extending this to the to the model
training side and and evolve it to this
towards a system where you can do a
training and evaluation basically in a
unified way
um i think that's a very exciting
perspective but
i think this this is gonna need a bit
more work at this point
so yeah
very interesting um so
let's go back to some of the things that
i know you're excited about in flink
right now um we've talked a bunch about
the architecture
we've talked a bunch about the basic
features and the unified analytics which
is unified streaming batch
um what about this concept of stateful
functions
can you talk to us about that and what
what the power of those are
yeah definitely um so the date for
functions is a as a pretty new project
so sub project
um and flink um can think about it like
that
um and um
yeah so maybe to explain what the idea
behind therefore functions is let's
let's look at a few like core
characteristics of data streaming
um or at least the way that most data
streaming systems be that like flink
kafka streams spark and so on work
so um what these systems do is they
they let you define um streaming a
stream a streaming data flow
meaning um sources where the events come
from and then
like a a directed i cyclic graph of of
streams and transformation operations
through which these events
events flow and then these
transformation operations might be
you know anything from filters might be
joining aggregating enriching
um and so on but you have a you have a
a pretty like rigid predefined flow and
that
that is also i think important because
that
that flow captures like a bit of the
interaction topology um
having a directed acyclic graph is also
important if you want
like the sophisticated time models of
event time and processing time tradeoff
and so on because time kind of
progresses then
also as you go through the as you go
through the directed
acyclic graph um stateful functions on
the other hand tries to drop a few of
these assumptions
um so why would you drop that um
it it tries to actually capture some of
these use cases that are closer to the
let's say not not the core data
processing side but more the event
driven application side
so um let's say use cases um where
um where folks like to use um let's say
things like actor system or um or other
event driven stuff rx java
these i think there's a lot of merit in
in
in some of these these abstractions in
the event driven application world
but i think there were a few very very
core things missing and that is this
notion of
of of consistent consistent state in
there
um which is something that actually
flink has solved very well on the on the
stream processing side so stay for
functions is really trying to be the
bridge between
if you wish the stream processing world
on the on the one hand
and the let's say reactive stateful
application world on the other
on the other hand so it's a it's a form
of
of of event processing that drops a few
notions of stream processing like you
know being restricted to a dac
and instead have dynamic messaging um
that and thus makes it a bit more
accessible to
um to reactive application developers
so stateful functions is is if you wish
a blend of
of actor programming and stream
processing okay
okay got it um well someone else had a
question that i want to go back to
um he actually wants to go back to state
how do you handle large states in flink
right so
so flink fling is actually able to
handle pretty large states so
if you if you look at like what is one
of the largest known use cases for
flinkers
is i think this um online recommendation
system and said alibaba and when they
have their crazy shopping holiday
i think the system carries up to 100
terabytes of state instead inside the
stream processor which is which is a lot
i would say for
remote for pretty much any database um
how does blink handle state so so first
of all it's um
it's a parallel it's a sharded system so
when when you have states that's usually
organized by key and
it belongs to belongs to to a key and
that that state
you know it might be the parameters
associated with the with the user
for you know for their their specific um
yeah for the for the recommender to you
know audition recommendations on that
user
or it it may be associated with um
with with the join so it's the
occurrences of an event for that key so
if you know if you want to join this
with another stream and an event with
the same key comes from that stream you
can lock up what what events
happened in the last five minutes on the
other stream so you can you know you can
join in
and combine them and so first of all um
status status charted by this key and
the streams are also co-sharded by the
by the keys um and then inside each
chart flink
um flink uses roxdb to to materialize
the the state and and make it accessible
um
by key and then um
it it actually um integrates that this
checkpointing mechanism
um with roxdb there's there's a pretty
interesting way roxdb is organized as a
lock structured merge tree so you can
actually
create immutable point in time snapshots
from from from rocksdb without actually
you know stopping the database you can
just
continue working it but you can pin if
you wish like a point in time
snapshot and that's what flink does i'm
doing during its checkpoint so it
actually creates these snapshots when
the
when when the flink checkpoint runs
through the operator and then it
basically diffs this with the previous
checkpoint and
and uploads the delta between this and
the previous checkpoint and that way it
can actually
scale up to a pretty large state um so
it can can have like tens of tens of
or hundreds of gigabytes in some cases
even on a node
um because it only acrom incrementally
needs to
upload the changes during checkpoints
what what you have to bear in mind
though is if you if you handle very
large state
when when one node really physically
crashes
recover it on another node you need to
kind of pull the state to that node so
this this knot is going to have a bit of
a pre-warming time
before it can continue processing just
because it needs to like pull all these
gigabytes
back into the into the local rocksdb
got it um someone else has asked a
question about deployment which i'm
excited about because i wanted to talk
to you
about that next um what is
the current and future recommended way
of running flink
on kubernetes via beam
which you beam supports flink as a
runtime
as i understand or some other way so
let's talk about deployment for a second
yeah so how do you deploy flink
there's actually a lot of answers to
this um this is partially due to the
fact that the set of use cases is so
wide so
if you would if you'd like to deploy
let's say a real-time streaming
application
um i think the the recommended way i
would say
is just use link on on kubernetes
and um deploy deploy flink asm
as an application um what does that mean
um maybe taking a step back flink blink
has a few different
ways you can think about it you can
think of link as either
a cluster of you know like a set of
processes you bring up and then you can
send them work let's say they're the
classic hadoop spark style or so
where you you know you start your
processing cluster and then you can open
a console and send that work their way
or you can you can basically say here
i'm i'm taking
this application putting it in a docker
image and then telling telling
kubernetes to start so many replicas of
that and then this is basically
it kind of it behaves like a
self-contained application
um you don't you don't have you know
notes that you can then later submit
other work to
and and and this kind of this is a bit
of a
i'd say two different approaches to
deployment that that come from the fact
that
you know fling tries to actually um
offer users
a natural way to do the the batch
processing style
work and the stream processing style
work and i think this deploying
something
pretty much like a natural application
of kubernetes or something that stream
a lot of the stream processing users
really like this is
you know configure a cluster bring it up
be that on yarn kubernetes and so on and
then
being able to connect with the client
tool and submit individual jobs that
you know might be short lived is just
something that a lot of bad users like
to do so
it kind of allows you to do both things
um
maybe coming back to the original
question for the streaming world yeah
there's there's a pretty natural way to
to deploy a flink application of
kubernetes by extending
just a flink image dropping user
application jar and
uh copying it in there and um
[Music]
yeah then then just deploying this
uncooperative
and what about the beam runner um the
flink runner and beam
yeah explain the the uses of that and
sort of
what's the sweet spot there are those
for for folks who are
presumably already running on google
cloud or are there other
meaningful use cases there in terms of
sort of optimal deployment
right so um so beam
is is um is mainly an
an and a unified api and
well it's it's not just an api it's
actually it's a very it's a very big
project
with you know there's the there's the
data flow api there's also a sql layer
on top of that and there's
like lots of connectors to it to various
um to various runtimes
um to beam flink is mainly a runtime
similar to how google cloud is a google
cloud dataflow is a runtime to beam so
a user writes an application against
against beam and then they can choose
where to run it
do they want to run it on flink on a you
know or do they want to run it on google
cloud do they want to run it on
um storm do they want to run it on on
samsa do they want to run it on
spark um there's there's lots of
different different runtimes with a
different
differently it's a broad coverage of the
of the feature set
i think beam is beam is interesting when
um
when you want to go for for something
like a um
let's say hybrid cloud strategies or if
you're
say a bit hesitant in in and committing
to to a system right if you want to
develop the application and
and you think like okay i'm really
interested in trying out this but
um i might you know eventually migrate
it to the cloud anyways go for a managed
service there
um then then beam gives you this
abstraction layer um
you know a little bit like
you could you could think of of sql
being being a language that is is cross
cross-compatible across different
databases so you know you write your you
write your
um analytics logic in in sql and then
it doesn't matter if you run it on
postgres or on mysql or an article
so you can you know you can you can
choose what the underlying system is so
beam tries to to to do exactly that um
and yeah and i think this um
this is very interesting it's a very
interesting um interesting approach and
and particularly interesting for for
folks that let's say have
um parts of their workload in the cloud
let's say on google cloud and parts of
the workload uh let's say on-prem
where they whether for example would
would um use flink as the underlying
execution on time
got it uh well one more
follow-up there um we're in in if you
don't have a comment on this it's no
problem but
where do you see a pulsar when compared
to flink
pulsar obviously is one of the more the
newer streaming projects
um i believe was that related was that
related to the
heron project or is that something
separate
um i think yes and no i think it was
commercially related to the heron
project
um technology-wise not not strictly
um so on the on the streaming side
there's
different layers also you can you can
look at right there's
if you wish there's the streaming
streaming storage
and transport and then there's streaming
computation i think you can draw a
parallel to the batch ecosystem where
there's
batch storage like hdfs s3 and so on and
then there's batch compute like
mapreduce spark hive
uh and so on and and pulsar
and um let's say the the the kafka
broker site and so on they're they're on
the on the storage side of things
um like you know the streaming
equivalent of
if you wish hdfs and s3 and so on and
um and flink and heron and um and kafka
streams and spark streaming they're on
the
on the computational side of things like
uh you know like spark and
mapreduce and hive so in in that sense
um it's not easy to compare
um to compare pulsar directly with with
fling because
pulsar is predominantly storage it has a
little bit of a complete compute set
with pulsar functions but i think so
it's a very
it's a very specific limited one
um versus link is really a compute a
compute system that
is usually complemented with a with a
streaming
storage um so yeah pulls out flink
actually can be used pretty well
together
um there's there's a connector between
the two systems there's actually a bunch
of companies that do that
so very interesting i think i think
posers pulsar's main you know um
equivalent
system would probably be kafka to
compare it understood
understood so rick is asking
is there a road map for expanding pi
flink user defined functions
to make them more suitable for ml
oriented python functions
right um so that that's actually a great
question so the
um i got i said in the beginning the the
initial support for
um for python that we started with was
with um
like user defined function in the table
api and there's there's a
a different set of user defined function
like
aggregation functions scalar functions
table functions and so on
and the
the that's the one side of it the other
side of it is like how how do you you
know
what kind of environments do you do you
support the execution and the support
environments where you have access to
native native libraries do you
how do you how do you interplay with for
example other um
other libraries in that space like um or
other apis like
like pandas or so um i think on both
sides there's
there's quite a bit of work on the um on
the python side so there's there's
definitely a lot of
a lot of work to to broaden the type of
functions that are supported in the
table api there's even
there's even work on adding python
support for the data stream api so you
can actually write
like very general purpose
map flat map process window functions in
python
and on the other side to to to add more
support for
um yeah for different interpreters and
easier interaction with
with existing native libraries and so on
i think the very best way to to to get
the details for that is actually on the
on the flink website
um in the wiki there is um what we call
flink improvement proposals
um it's basically the list of of big
features it's probably the the best way
to look at the at the road map
um and this there's always
some some flips in each release that
that talk about um the extended support
for python
to be quite frank that's also the place
where i would go to look up the details
now
are you happy with the level of python
support from the community so far
are you looking for additional
committers
um i i think the python site
would be happy to take on a committer or
two yeah
um it's one of the newer features so
it's it's
i think less than a year that the python
support exists in flink so
these newer features um yeah they
they usually tend to to take a release
or two before they start forming up like
a
like a real user and committer base
because you know once a once a new
version is released
it also takes usually a bit until
until users pick it up um then until you
know that they've tried out enough to
um to really get back to the community
get involved with okay this works this
doesn't work and so on so
yeah i i would actually say that the
python sets uh it's a pretty good side
to
to get in get involved in if you're
interested in and being active in the
community maybe
yeah great are you joining that's great
that's great to know
well um we're we're essentially at time
staphon
um this has been a great conversation um
i just wanted to ask you before we leave
what are you most excited about on the
roadmap for flink going forward
that's not an easy question there's
there's a lot of stuff happening always
um it's hard it's hard to choose so
there are a lot of things out in the in
the current and in the previous release
that i was really excited about maybe
let me
let me start with that some of these
excitements already you know come to a
closure
if you wish um so this extension of of
the streaming
of sql and streaming streaming sequel
coming coming together like
i tried to explain it earlier this is
something i i
find really really fascinating and very
cool like this is a this is a very big
deal
um combine this together with
um like the change data capture support
that that flink 111 added and you
actually have a pretty
like a pretty neat neat story from you
know like from from attaching
link to to a mainframe or another
database grab changes of the log
compute materialize views and store them
in another system so
like basically building an
infrastructure around like
services on materialized use this this
is this is an extremely cool thing
um we already talked about the python
side of things
um definitely very nice um
what what i like in in the features
we're working on at the moment
is i think we're
we're very short before kind of
closing closing the the circle on the
batch streaming unification also on the
data stream api
um the batch streaming unification works
pretty well on sql and on the table api
the data stream api
as basically the earlier api that we had
has a few things and has a bit yeah
has a few things in there that that that
do need some work
in order to make this work equivalently
well on the batch side and also
the data stream api not going through an
optimizer means that we
we can't rely on something that
magically not changes execution models
between batch and streaming like
like i explained before but we actually
have to come up with a different
physical way to
translate these operators between
veterans streaming and um we're very
close to actually completing this so
there's um this is something we're
working on for this release
so that i think that that's that's
something i also i also really like
like this like rounding up this um
running up the story
um there's a little bit of of work we're
doing
on the um on the full tolerance side and
um like without saying too much because
this is
um not all of that is is yet beyond the
let's say research and prototype stage
but there's there's a few things we're
working on and uh in that area
um that that i think are gonna make a
pretty big difference
um some of the biggest changes we did
we're doing in the system or we're
researching in the system
um since you know flink actually started
with streaming and
introduced the checkpointing model so um
with the yeah with the ultimate goal of
um
of really making making checkpoints
very robust very very fast um speeding
speeding up recovery
um by like by orders of magnitude and so
on and
there's there's some i think there's
some stuff that that
we're going to see being proposed to the
open source community in the next months
that
that i'm i'm very very excited about
awesome that's great and and last
question
um what surprised you most about your
work
on flink over all these years
what surprised me most um
i mean
very very high level speaking the the
fact that
you know this this prototype that a few
students at university
um stitched together actually
was was interesting enough to form in
such a big community
and user base that that that is
fascinating that's that i still
sometimes don't get quite over that
um the other part
um yeah i don't know how many
how many things do
do in the end come together in such a
nice way under this streaming umbrella i
said this at the at the very beginning
like streaming is is a bit of a
bit of a nice unifying paradigm for
for various things and i have the
feeling the the more we
we work on this the more it actually
shows in almost every layer of the
system not just like in the apis but
like also in the in the runtime um
you start to work on something and then
then you figure out like okay here's
there's
something that doesn't perfectly work
and you see like okay we're actually
doing it a little too patchy here and
you know like in a pure streaming where
you do it like this and then you pull it
through and like all of a sudden
everything works super well
um and it works super well across the
bash and and streaming side so this
yeah how there's really a
i think there's a beauty in the
streaming paradigm if you if you if you
see it if you see it completely to the
end
and both in the conceptual and in the in
the
implementation layers and um
i think we're i think there's this like
we as
a world as a whole haven't actually
really reached that that point where
where all of these things come
come together finally we're getting bit
by bit closer
like various projects are working on
this link being being one of them and
i think i think it's a pretty it's a
pretty cool thing it's going to be a big
impact on
on on infrastructure for the future when
when we see this come to fruition
well thank you for being such an
evangelist um for the streaming paradigm
and and for being so eloquent in the way
that you describe it
um thanks for all your work on flink and
the community over the years
um i think it is a true example of a
amazing community project which we love
to support here at data council
um and i'm hoping that you'll pick up
some some more interested users some
contributors
um from this conversation and that will
be helpful for you in the same community
so
so thanks for joining us stefan it was
great to have you here yeah thank you
very much for having me it was a lot of
fun visa
it's a great great discussion thanks so
much thank you and thanks to the rest of
the community for all your questions
um we'll see you next time bye